[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلو هذا ابرز
العناوين
في ثاني قرار هذا العام الوكاله الذريه
تامر ايران بالتعاون مع تحقيقها بشان اثار
اليورانيوم وعقوبات امريكيه جديده على
طهران
[تصفيق]
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه تكشف مكونات
امريكيه ويابانيه في صناعه الايرانيه الى
روسيا
بعباره لا خلافات سياسيه ابديه اردوغان
يجدد احتمال لقائه ببشار الاسد لكن بعد
الانتخابات التركيه
عدنان من البكتيريا الضاره التغير المناخي
ينظر سكان الارض بكارثه وشيكا سببها ذوبان
الجليد
[موسيقى]
قرار بصيغه الامر صدر عن الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه يدعو ايران التعاون بشكل
عاجل في التحقيق بشان اثار الايرانيوم في
ثلاثه مواقع سريه غير معلنه القرار الذي
تم التصويت عليه خلف ابواب مغلقه حصل على
تاييد سته وعشرين صوتا واعطيرات صوتين فقط
القرار هو الثاني الذي يصدر هذا العام
موجها لايران بشان التحقيقات النوويه الذي
اصبح عقب امام محادثات اعاده احياء
الاتفاق النووي المواقع في عام 2015 لان
طهران تطالب بانهاء التحقيق فيها اولا وهو
ما ترفضه طبعا الوكاله الدوليه التي
اعتبرت قرارها تمديدا بعد تعاون ايران
نوويه وبعد قرار الوكاله بقليل صدر بيان
الماني فرنسي بريطانيا رفض الضغط على
الوكاله واكد ان تحقيق مفتوح منذ اربع
سنوات وايران لم تتعاون حتى الان
[موسيقى]
وسبك القرار بيان اوروبي اكد فيه او اكتب
فيها ان ايران اختارت الضغط السياسي
لاغلاق التحقيق عوضا عن الوفاء بواجباتها
كما رفض البيان بشكل القاطع اي ضغوط
سياسيه على الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
هذا وكان مدير الوكاله رافاييل جروسي قال
امس انه لا يجوز ان يبقى التحقيق في اثار
يورانيوم سريه مفتوحه للابد من دون الحصول
على جواب فيما حضر سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي
ايران من ان عدم تعاونها السريع مع
الوكاله سيؤدي الى تصعيد اكبر وان الدول
الغربيه ستناقش خطواتها المقبله في حال لم
تبدي ايران تعاونا سريعا وقال دبلوماسي
اوروبي للعربيه ان لدى الدول الغربيه
خيارات كثيره يمكنها اللجوء اليها في حال
لم تتعاون ايران بشكل سريع
اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات
جديده على طهران العقوبات جاءت على خلفيه
قمع الاحتجاجات في ايران وتشمل شركات
للنفط والغاز وتستهدف 13 شركه تسهل بيع
منتجات بتروكيماويه ايرانيه ب 100 ملايين
الدولارات
للمشترين في شرقي اسيا
بدوره رحب ممدوب مندوب السعوديه لدى
الوكاله الدوليه الامير عبد الله بن خالد
بن سلطان باعتماد مجلس محافظين وكاله
مشروع القرار الذي يعكس قلق اعضاء المجلس
حيل التجاوزات الايرانيه المستمره وعدم
تعاونها مع الوكاله لحل القضايا النوويه
العالقه وطالب الدول الاعضاء اتخاذ موقف
حازم لمواجهه السلوك الايرانيه غير
المسؤول لضمان امني واستقرار المنطقه
والعالم اجمع
تنضم الينا من فينا راغده بهدان مفردات
العربيه رغده ما هي الخطوات التصعيديه
التي يمكن ان تلجا اليها الوكاله والمجتمع
الغربي بعد يعني قبيله التصريح الايراني
الغير مرحب عشيت هذا القرار
اهلا بك يا مساء الخير يعني الان يعني هذا
المشروع وهذا القرار الذي تم التصويت عليه
سيمنحران بعض الوقت لكي تتوضح الصوره اكثر
ايران لم تبلغ الوكاله الرسميه بعد ما اذا
كان سيكون هناك اجتماع كما الاتفاق عليه
هنا الاسبوع الماضي كان من المفترض ان
يحصل في طهران قبل نهايه هذا الشهر هذا
الامر ما زال معلقا الوكاله ما زالت تنتظر
رد همم من ايران همم القرار يعني اهميته
همم يعني هو يختلف عن قرار الذي صدر في
يونيو الماضي بانه يلمح او يشير ضمير يعني
الى انه يمكن ان يكون هناك خطوات تصعيديه
او رائحه ايران الى مجلس الامن في حال لم
يكن هناك تعاون هذه الاشاره الضنيه هي
جاءت في عبارتين كما شرح لنا احد
دبلوماسيين داخل مجلس المحافظين همم هو
قال او ذكر هذا القرار بانه مجلس
المحافظين يقرر ان يدعو ايران بشكل عاجل
وضرورها ثاني كلمتان تحيان او تشيرن بحسب
النظام الاساسي للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه البند 12 عندما اعتقد هناك امكانيه
يعني بعد استخدامها ثاني الكلمتين بان
يكون هناك احاله لمجلس الامن في حال لم
يكن هناك تعاون بالنقاط التي حددها القرار
ودعاء ايران لاعطاء اجوبه تقنيه تكون
مقبوله للوكاله دعها ايضا ل همم اعطاء او
الافصاح عن اماكن التي يخزن تخزن فيها اثر
اليورانيوم التي عثر عليها في هذه الاماكن
السريه ولا تحديد مكان او اماكن
السريه هذا او المواقع السريه الثلاث لذلك
الان هناك مهله زمنيه قبل ان يكون هناك
تصعيد ولكن هذه يعني هذا التصعيد هو موجود
او ضميا موجود فيها هذا همم القرار الذي
صدر همم اليوم في حال كان الرد الايراني
او التعاطي الايراني مع هذا القرار كما
كان مع القرار الاول او المنصرم ماذا
سيكون الرد كم هي المهله المعطات اليوم
لايران
يمكن القياس على الاجتماع المقبل لمجلس
المحافظين مجلس المحافظين سيجتمعين في
المره المقبله في شباط او في مارس المقبل
يعني بعد بضعه اشهر من الانثلاثه ثلاثه
ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا من الان سيعود وينعقد
في دور عاديه وفي هذا الاجتماع سيعود
ويبحث بناء على تقرير رافاييل جراسي مدير
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذي سيطلع
المجلس على التقدم او عدم هذا التقدم بناء
عليه سيعود المجلس لمناقشه هذه المساله
يقرر حينها اما يقرر اعطاء ايران ولا
جديده اضافيه ام يقرر حينها بانه سياخذ
الخطوات التصعيديه ويحيلها او يحيل هذا
الملف ملف عدم التعاون الى مجلس الامن همم
ممكن تتحدث
قبل ان يصدر هذا القرار وسالته يعني حول
هذه النقطه ما اذا كان هناك تخوف من ان
يؤدي هذا القرار الى تعقيد العلاقه اكثر
مع ايران
ويؤدي الى وضع اسوا قال بانه الوضع الان
جدا اا بمعنى انه التوقعات هي اصلا يعني
الوضع سيء الى ما الى اي حد يمكن ان يسوء
اكثر همم لذلك همم ليس هناك امل كبير ربما
لدى الاطراف الغربيه هنا بان يكون هناك
تعاون ايراني ولكن هناك تهديد جدي ومتزايد
بان يعود ملف ايران الى مجلس الامن وهذا
يعني يكون همم تصعيد كبير جدا ويعني
بالنسبه لايران ليس لا يصب في مصلحه ايران
وطبيعه الحال لانه
موضوع عاده لمجلس الامن للمره الاولى بعد
ان تم الاتفاق عام 2015 وكانت خرجت من
المجلس وخرجت من هذه دائره الضغوط الدوليه
الكبيره وبالتالي العوده الى النقطه الصفر
شكرا لك راغده احنا مو فده العربيه حدثنا
[موسيقى]
في اخر التطورات الميدانيه لا تزال
المعارك متواصله بين الجيش الروسي
والاوكراني في الشرقيه وجنوب البلد حيث
تقوم وحدات من الجيش الروسي بضرب بعض
الاماكن التي تمركزت فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه مؤخرا في خرسون والتي تسببت
بوقوع سلسله انفجارات امتدت الى مدينه
نيبرو في حين تشهد المناطق القريبه من
دونياس في منطقه دونباس الشرقيه وايضا
مدينتي بخموط وابديفكا ضربات صاروخيه
متفرقه وقصف مدفعي مكثف هذا وتم تسجيل في
مدينه تاميل
كما اعلن الدفاع الاوكرانيه عن حاله
التاهب جوي في اكياف ومدن اوكرانيه اخرى
تحسبا لها هجمات روسيه بعد وقوع قصر
استهدف مدينه اودس
في الوقت ذات الذي رجحت فيه وارسو وان تو
اطلاق الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني صاروخا
هبطاع عن طريق الخطا في بولندا اذا وكشف
مسؤول اوكراني سعي بلاده لبناء نظام دفاعي
جوي متكامل ومنصق مع الحلفاء حيث قال وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني انكياف تعمل مع حلفاء
دوليين لبناء نظام دفاع جوي يمكنها من
خلاله التصدي لكافه الضربات الجويه
الروسيه فيما المح الرئيس الاوكرانيه
تزويد اسرائيل لكياف بانظمه الدفاع جويه
بقوله ان نتانيا هو فقط على النظر في دعم
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
بقطع امريكيه ويابانيه تصنع ايران
مسيراتها المرسله الى روسيا والتي
تستخدمها الاخيره لضرب البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه معلومات كشفت استخبارات لصحيفه
معلومات استخباراتيه اكدت ان ثلاثه ارباع
مكونات الايرانيه المستخدمه ضد اوكرانيا
امريكيه في اشاره الى مسيرات مهاجر سته
وشاهد 136 التي تم تصنيعها باجزاء ومعدات
غربيه المعلومات الاستخباراتيه كشفت عن
اكبر سلسله توريد غربي للمسيرات الايرانيه
التي تشمل المحركات ولوحات التحكم وانظمه
المراقبه فلقد اوضح الجيش الاوكراني ان
اكثر من 200 مكون داخلي لمو سيارات مهاجر
16 وشاهد 136 تم تصنيعها نصفها بواسطه
شركات مقرها في الولايات المتحده وحوالي
بواسطه شركه في اليابان فعلى سبيل المثال
مسيرات شهد 136 والتي اطلق عليها اسم
طائرات كاميكازي فتح تم تصنيعه من
المكونات الالكترونيه الخاصه بها من قبل
وحدات انفينيون تكنولوجيا المملوكا بي
المانيا وشركه اي جي ميكروتشيب تكنولوجيا
اي ان سي ومقرها اليسونو وبخصوص مسيرات
مهاجر سته فلقد تم تصنيع القطع التي تدعم
المحركات الخاصه بها من قبل شركه يابانيه
والتي تسمح للمشغلين بمناوره للمركبه غير
الماهوله عبر الهواء في حين يرى خبراء
عسكريون بان حدثت الاشعه تحت الحمراء
التلسكوبيه عاليه الدقه المستخدمه في
مهاجر سته للمراقبه والاستهداف مطابقه
للنموذج صنعته شركه اسرائيليه
كما ان معهد العلوم والامن الدولي مقر
واشنطن قال ان الشركات الصينيه زودت ايران
بنسخ من السلع الغربيه لانتاج الطائرات
القتاليه بدون طيار
[موسيقى]
قال كبير مستشار الدفاع البريطانيه لشؤون
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا في مقابله مع
العربيه ان استخدام روسيا للمسيرات
الايرانيه يظهر فشل موسكو اشاره الى ان
العلاقات الجيده بين الدول يجب ان لا تكون
مع ايران
دفع ايراني
وهذا يدل على الفشل الروسي العلاقه مع
ايران هي مؤشر على العلاقه التي لم تؤدي
الى النجاح ايران لديها تاريخ انفزعت
استقرار المنطقه والتصرف بسلوك لا يرغب به
احد في بادئ الامر ايران تجاهلت انكرت هذا
الامر لكنها الان تعترف بتزويدها روسيا
بالمسيرات العلاقه بين روسيا وايران
العسكريه والامنيه بعد التقدير الذي
استفناه قبل قليل السؤال الاساسي كيف يمكن
ان تصل اجزاء اساسيه وبكميات كبيره الى
داخل ايران وسط كل العقوبات المفروضه على
النظام الايراني
دبي
اذا ما نظرتي الى معدات الجيش الروسي وكم
حجم
القطعه الالكترونيه الغربيه
فهذه مساله تتعلق بايران وايران تجد دائما
طرقا
لتتهرب من العقوبات هذه هي حقيقه بالنسبه
للامريكيين ما مدى هم فاعلون
نعم يعني ايران من المعلوم انها دائما
استخدمت المقايضه والصفقات السريه
والتهريب لدعم اقتصاده بعد العقوبات ولكن
هنا نتحدث عن كميات كبيره وحتى لو جرى
شراؤها بالسوق السوداء شحنها يخضع لعقوبات
ايضا ولمراقبه دوليه كيف يمكن تمرير هذه
الكميات الكبيره عبر كل هذه الانظمه
الدوليه التي يعني من المفروض انها تراقب
هذا الموضوع
بانه يوجد اكثر من 2400 من هذه المسيارات
كما تعلمون الروسيه تعون لشراء صواريخ ارض
ارض وهي سوف يتم تسليمها في الفتره
القريبه وهذا سوف يعمل على تصعيد من حجه
ولابد من الاشاره الى ان هناك مشكله في
الدفاع الجوي في المنطقه ولابد لهم من فعل
شيء اذا هذا الامر
المملكه بالامارات بضرب اسرائيل يعني
وبالتالي نتحدث عن تهديد الامن القومي
للمنطقه واليوم يتضح بان يعني جميع القطع
المستخدمه هي الغربيه هلا يطرح كثير من
علامات الاستفهام كيف يمكن ان تتعاطى
السلطات الغربيه مع هذا الموضوع
برايت
اذا احد الامر لكن قد فات الاوان كما ذكرت
ومن جهه اخرى
نعلمه ان الاقتصادات وخاصه الاقتصاد
الدفاعي الخاص بايران منهج للغايه بسبب
دعم ايران لحزب الله
ودعمها للحوثيين في اليمن
كما تعلمون ولا تستطيعوا ايرا ان تقوم بسد
احتياجات ما تطلبه روسيا من هذه الاسلحه
بالعوده الى مسار الحرب الاوكرانيا روسيه
بعد الانسحاب الروسي الاخير من المتوقع
اليوم ان تكون المرحله المقبله في الشرق
وايضا في الجنوب عند بحر ازوف ايضا القوات
الاوكرانيه من المتوقع
واليوم الروس لديهم نقطه قوه
بالنسبه للمساحه ما المتوقع بهذه معركه
كبيرا مع قدوم الفصل الشتاء هو قد لا تكون
الامور
مرتكزه فقط
ونشدوا الان الحربين في نفس الوقت هناك
حرب
لا تزال المبادره للقوات الاوكرانيه
المدنيه وهنا وقد يكون الاختبار الحقيقي
لاخرا ومن يدعمها فلابد من زياده دعم حجم
الدفاعات الجويه التي تقدم الى المدن وهذه
سوف تكون الازمه في الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]
اختتم ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان زيارته الى كوريا الجنوبيه التي
شهدت توقيع اتفاقيات ومذكرات تفاهم في
قطاعات مختلفه نتعرف على ابرز محطات هذه
الزياره في التقرير الثالث
الامير محمد بن سلمان الى المحطه الثانيه
ضمن جولته الاسيويه كوريا الجنوبيه اختمت
باعلان صفقات واستثمارات تتجاوز قيمتها
عشرات المليارات من الدولارات لتاخذ
البلدين الى درجه اعلى من التقارب
الاقتصادي والتجاريه خلال الزياره عقد
الامير محمد بن سلمان جلسه مباحثات اولى
مع رئيس الوزراء هاندا سو تناوله فيها سبل
تعزيز العلاقات والتعاون المشترك في مختلف
المجالات ثلاث جلسه مباحثات رسميه عقدها
ولي العهد السعودي بحضور وحزين من البلدين
حيث كان على راس الوفد الكوري رئيس كوريا
الجنوبيه يونس يوكيو اكد خلال هذه الامير
محمد بن سلمان على عمق العلاقات وان كوريا
الجنوبيه تعد شريكا استراتيجيا للسعوديه
على مدى الستين عاما الماضي
60 عاما على انشاء العلا المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وجمهوريه كوريا مما يؤكد رغبه
بلدينا في الاستمرار في ترسيخ اسس هذه
العلاقه التاريخيه والعمل على استكمال
الجهود الرميه الى تعزيز التعاون في جميع
المجلات
مستقبل استثماري ضخم بين الرياض وصول حيث
جرى خلال الزياره ابرام 25 عقدا ومذكره
تتفاهم بقيمه 29 مليار دولار وضمن جدول
زيارته لتقولي العهد السعودي عددا من
رؤساء كبرى الشركات الكوريه واستعرض معهم
فرص الاستثمار في التكنولوجيا والصناعه
والتشييد والمدن الذكي تعاون وثيق جمع
البلدين ضمن اطار الرؤيه السعوديه الكوريه
2030 وتنسيق استثماري عال عزز من الشراكه
الممتده لسته عقود
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
قتلى وجرحى في انفجار في مدينه السليمانيه
بكردستان العراق
[موسيقى]
جميع امراض الدم والاورام للكبار والاطفال
العلاج الكيميائي الطب النووي امراض الدم
والاورام وامراض المناعه والغدد اللمفاويه
بكفاءات طبيه متميزه المواساه خبره تنبض
الثقه بعد غزوه بغرب اوروبا وسيطرته عليها
وفي ذروه قوته وثقته بنفسه كان متاكدا
بانه خطير ليقود المانيا للسيطره على
العالم وبعد فشل مفاوضاته مع موسكو قرر
اجتياحها وثائقي يروي قصه اكبر غزو بري في
التاريخ
صعود النازيين بارباروسا الجمعه الواحده
بعد منتصف الليل على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
بكل ثقه
تصل بنا الى اهدافنا
سواء كنا لاعبين او محللين او مشجعين
يتخطى الذين نعرفه عالم اكثر شفافيه متوجا
بالمجد تعيش فيه اجمل اللحظاتنا قد ننجح
وقد نتعثر لكننا
لمحلق حاليا بشكل اسرع واقوى وافضل فنحن
واثقون من انفسنا من المضيق قدما الكره
السعوديه في المرمى مع بتالي الجوز من
الثلاثاء الى الخميس منتصف الليل على شاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
قد يعيد النظر في العلاقات مع رئيس النظام
السوري بشار الاسد بعد الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقرر اجرائها في
تركيا في حزيران يونيو من العام المقبل
ورده على سؤال حول احتمال عقده لقاء مع
الاسد قال اردوغان انه لا يوجد استياء او
خلاف ابدي في السياسه
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول جواد جوك المحلل
السياسي استاذ جواد هي ليست الاشارات
الايجابيه الاولى بعد اللقاء الاستخبارات
التي سرب عنه بالاشهر الماضيه وخصوصا ان
الجانب الروسي يدعم هذا التقارب التركي
السوري لماذا الان الاعلان عنه قبل
الانتخابات هل هو موضوع اللاجئين فقط ام
ماذا
الكرام طبعا الحكومه التركيه مهتمه بهذا
الموضوع لانه
قبيله الانتخابات بحاجه الى رعود للناس
للشارع التركي احد اسباب همم تراجع شعبيه
حزب الحاكم في تركيا قضيه قضيه اللاجئين
وبصراحه هذه القضيه ان تنحل لان جميع
الاحزاب المعارضه
تتواعد انه انهم سوف يقومون بترحيل
السوريين خاصه بشكل اجباري الى بلادهم همم
القوميه صارت متطرفه الحزب الحاكم يريد ان
يحل المشكله بشكل اخر ولهذا السبب يعلنون
من ضروره التواصل مع حكومه
تعتبر ورقه قويه بيد المعارضه للرئيس
اردوغان بالداخل والاحزاب المعارضه ولكن
في حال ذهب الى ايجاد حل من المعلوم انه
يجب ان يوقع بعض البروتوكولات لعوده
السوريين الى هناك منها ضمان عدم الملاحقه
الامنيه وضمان امن هؤلاء هل هو سهل بظل
عدم اللقاء العلني بين كل من اردوغان
والاسد
طبعا
مشاكل مستمره في سوريا بشكل اخر لكن
بصراحه يعني السياسات الحكومه التركيه
اتجاه سوريا كانت سياسه خاطئه يعني من
البدايه قالوا ضروره اسقاط نظام بشار
الاسد جاءوا الى نقطه واحده الاراضي
السوريه لانه تهدد امن القومي التركي الان
فكروا مثلا في شمالي سوريا عندما تكون
قوات خاصه مستقره هناك دعم الامريكي او
الغربي لو ترفع رايات السوريه بدلا من
رايات الامريكيه همم بقرايات قصد هذا
لمصلحه تركيا ولهذا السبب الحكومه التركيه
تعترف انه تواصل مباشر مع حكومه دمشق كل
ما تزيد قوه وسيطره حكومه الى اراضي
السوريه هذه لمصلحه تركيا بشكل لكن
شاكر مستمره كمان في سوريا يعني دخول
تركيا الى الملف السوري اعاد الى المنطقه
وهي اعادت موضعها بعد يعني تغيير موازين
القوى الروسيه اليوم موضوع شمال سوريا
والعمليه العسكريه التركيه اين ستصبح بعد
هذا الاعلان بالسياسه بين كل من اردوغان
والاسد
طبعا انا لا اظن ان تقوم الحكومه التركيه
القوات التركيه بعمليه عسكريه واسعه في
شماليه سوريا بالنتيجه هذه القضيه بحاجه
الى ضوء اخضر من الجانب الروسي واذا في
تطبيق العلاقات مع سوريا نحن نقول على
الحكومه التركيه ان تت- تتحرك مع
اشقائنا العربي هناك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه امارات وبقيه دول خاصه دوله مصر
المهمه في المنطقه على الحكومه التركيه ان
تقوم بالتنسيق معهم تطبيق العلاقات مع مصر
خاصه مهمه جدا اذا تتحرك مع دول العربيه
في حل هذه القضيه انا اظن انهم سوف يصلون
الى النتيجه مطلوبه في قضيه سوريا فتح
قنوات الحوار المباشره خصوصا نتحدث عن
تركيا راعي اسبانيا هل ممكن ان يفتح من
جديد او او يجب ان يفتح من جديد موضوع
النقاش السياسي والمرحله الانتقاليه
وايجاد الحل السياسي للازمه السوريه
طبعا الحكومه التركيه ترجع انت محل
المشكله
بلقاءات بناء بين المعارضه والحكومه
السوريه لكن المعارضه هنا لازالت موقفها
سلبيه جدا من حكومه دمشق لكن بشكل او اخر
قضيه سوريا لا تنحل
بالطرق الحربيه او القتال او دعم
المجموعات
المتطرفه في شمال سوريا ولهذا السبب
الحكومه في هذا الاطار لا لا بد ان تتحرك
مع جانب الروسي خاصه بوتن يشجع على ان
تتحرك تركيا همم
يعني نحو اللقاء بين الجانبين
نحن نعرف ان الرئيس اردوغان منذ سنه لا
تصرح سلبيا ضد شخصيات بشار الاسد وغير ذلك
كانه نرى ضوءا في اخر النفق شكرا لك يا
استاذ جواد
سياسي حدثنا من اسطنبول
تحرك اممي جديد لكشف مصير الاف السوريين
المعتقلين بسجون نظام الاسد بسوريا
فالتزامن مع تقرير دقيقه اصدرته صحيفه
الجاردن البريطانيه كشف كذب وتدليس ما
يقال انها قوانين عفو اصدرها الاسد لم
يخرج بموجبها الا عشرات من مرتكبي الجرائم
الجنائيه في حين بقي المعتقلون وما اكثرهم
في السجون صوتت الجمعيه العمل للامم
المتحده على قرار جعله الامين العام للامم
المتحده لانشاء مؤسسه دوليه جديده مختصره
بمعالجه قضيه المفقودين في سوريا كخطوه
اولى نحو تحقيق العداله في البلاد وسيشر
الامين العام للامم المتحده قريبا دراسه
طلبت في قرار همم للجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده حول كيفيه تعزيز الجهود لتوضيح
مصير المفقودين في سوريا
[موسيقى]
قالت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه ان عدد
القتلى جرى الاحتجاجات على مستوى البلاد
ارتفع الى
342 قتيلا على الاقل خلال ال 24 ساعه
الماضيه واضافت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه ايضا ان بعض المعتقلين معرضون
لخطر الاعدام في محاكمات سواريه مشيره الى
احتجاز الاف الاشخاص في الشهرين الماضيه
في وقت سابق حذرت منظمه العفو الدوليه في
تقرير لها من ان القوات الامن تستخدام
رصاصات الحرب القاتله في حمله القمه ضد
الناس في المحافظه وتظهر الادله التي
جمعتها منظمه العفو من الدوليه ان غالبيه
القتل والجرحى استهدفوا بالرصاص القاتل
وان اصابات الطلقات الناريه في رؤوسهم
وصدورهم وجذورهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعتبر المخرج الايرانيه المعارض بناه بناه
نجل المخرج السينمائي السجين جعفر بناهي
ان التشديد القمع في ايران على ما على
الياس المطلق الذي اصاب النظام الديني
ووصف بناهي درجه الياس هذه بغير المسبقه
مشيرا الى ان السجون ايران لم يعد لها
متسعه لاستعاب السجناء الجدد وان النظام
بلغ الطريق المسدود
الحياه في ايران تغيرت عن السابق واصبح
هناك جيل لا يخشى القمع وادواته هكذا يقول
محتاج هنا ايرانيون فجموع الايرانيين تلك
تبدو كانها اتخذت قرارها باحداث تغيير
انهم لا يخافون او تضربهم
اليوميه الايرانيه فان ثلاثه وتسعين من
المحتاجين تقل اعمارهم عن الخامسه
والعشرين واضاف معهد الشرق الاوسط في
واشنطن ان ابناء الجيل الايرانيه الحالي
قد حذوا بفرصه للحصول على معلومات
والتواصل مع العالم الخارجي افضل من تلك
التي اطيحت لابائهم واجدادهم
تلك البنايات ترمي عليهم الحجاره واذا
كانت البنايه من اربعه طوابق فجميع
الطوابق ترمي
الحجاره فقط هناك بعض اللقطات بهذا الخصوص
وشاهدتموها كانوا يرمون مزهريات على
رؤوسنا وضربوا زملائنا بالمكواه والبراميل
ورموا علينا طاولات وكراسي
وفي احدث اشكال قمع الاحتجاجات قتل
مهاجمون على دراجات ناريه سبعه اشخاص
بالرصاص بينهم امراه وطفلا في مدينه ايزيل
واقعه غربي ايران في حين رصدت منظمات
حقوقيه اطلاق النار في ست مدن الكبرى على
الاقل وفي سجون ايران واقع اصاب بحسب
المخرج الايراني المعارض بنا بناهيه الذي
قال ان المعتقلات لم يعد بها متسع
لاستيعاب السجناء الجدد مضيفا ان الحكومه
الايرانيه المستقبليه ستعلن من سجن افين
الذي يصدمه خبره وكفاءات حنان المصري
العربيه
[موسيقى]
وفي العراق كشف مراسل العربيه في اقليم
كردستان عن وقائع انفجار ضخم في مجمع
كويجا بمدينه السليمانيه واسفل الانفجار
حسب ما افاد مراسل العربيه عن سقوط عدد من
القتلى والجرحى وانهيار ثلاثه منازل سكنيه
وذلك نتيجه الانفجار الذي اتضح لاحقا ان
هناك نجم عن منظومه خاص
تشدد في الخرطوم التظاهرات التي تطالب
بحكم مدني كامل في السودان كما تاتي
التظاهره بذكر احتجاجات السابع عشر من
نوفمبر التي قتل فيها 15 متظاهره
[موسيقى]
كيف الحال انا ما كنت اساعدك
الله
[موسيقى]
انا لانه
هاقول لك العربيه
والله
[موسيقى]
من السودان الى تونس حيث عاشت مدينه صفاقس
على واقعه حركنا احتجاج امام مقر المحافظه
والبلديه على خلفيه ازمه النفايات بالجهاء
وحرق مكان با النفايات بطريقه الميناء
بمدينه صفاقس الاحتجاجات جاءت بدعوه من
منظمات المجتمع المدني وشارك فيها الاهالي
مطالبين بالتدخل الفوري لانحاء الاسماء
الى الشارع مره اخرى ينزل اهالي اسفاقس
ولسانه حالهم يقول صفاقس تستغيث بعد ما
غرقت في النفايات واختنقت جراء احراقي عدد
كبير بالالاف الاطناني من هذه النفايات في
احد المكبات وسط المدينه
[تصفيق]
هذه هي الازمه التي جاوزت السنه لا يمكن
تعاطي معها الا بالرفع الفوري للفضلات
المتراكمه وتعاطي معها ايضا بحلول اجله
عبر تسمين هذه النفايات هكذا تحدث منظم
هذه الوقفه الاحتجاجيه حول
المركزي خضر هنا في سباق والا يمكن ما
يحبش اسمع معنا بس يطلعوا في تحركات على
المستوى العاصمه همم على ملك الوصل وصوتنا
وكلنا نلقاه يكون يعتبرنا مواطنين كامل
الحقوق والواجبات
واقف انتظار هي رفع اعلاف التي تقدست في
مختلف ارجاء المدينه مع تواصل اغلاق
مكباتها الرئيسيه يهدد الاهالي ومنظمات
المجتمع المدنيه باتخافي خطوات تصعيديه
اكبر وذلك بالتوجه في يوم غضب الى العاصمه
مع التهديد بمقاطعه الانتخابات التشريعيه
القادمه من وسط مدينه صفاقس لقناتي
العربيه والحدث والاد عبد الله تونس
التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
الامم المتحده تعلن بدء تفريغ الناقله
صافر مطلع العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بالرغم من الفارق الضئيل
الذي فاز به الجمهوريين بمجلس النواب
انه يكفي لتعطيل اجنده الرئيس جو بايدن
وحزبه الديمقراطي للعامين المقبلين بما في
ذلك التاثير على السياسه الخارجيه للبلاد
الجمهوريين في الكونغرس الجديد الذي سيبدا
مهامه في يناير المقبل سيجنون ثمار فوزهم
عندما تمنح قواعد مجلس النواب الحزب
المسؤول السيطره على التشريع كما سيدير
الجمهوريون ايضا جميع الايشان مجلس النواب
مع سلطات اشراف واسعه بما في ذلك سلطه
الاستدعاء والرقبه ما قد يزعج الرئيس
ويعرقل بعض القرارات واول شيء سيعمل عليه
الجمهوريون قد يكون انهاء تكليف لجنه
التحقيق في احداث الكابتل والتي يشكل فيها
الرئيس السابق ترامب المتهم الاول فيها
وبما يخص دعم اوكرانيا سيحصل جمهوريون على
صلاحيه تمكنهم من تقليل الانفاق العسكري
في دعمك خلال الحرب مع روسيا خصوصا وانا
في وطن جمهوريه كانت قد المحت الى وضع
عقبات امام دعم الاداره لاوكرانيا
الجمهوريون سيسعون ايضا الى حد كبير
لتقليص الانفاق الفيدرالي والسعاده
استقلال الطاقه بالرغم من ان التجمع
الجمهوري المنقسم قد لا يتفق على الكثير
من النقاط لكنهم سيكونون قادرين على ايقاف
اجوند تشوبايدين فيما اعلنت المخضرمنانسي
قبل قليل تخليها عن زعامه ديمقراطيين في
الكونغرس
[موسيقى]
صابتني
فتح وتحقيقا حول مدى تورط الرئيس
والاشجار الدولي للبشر وغسيل الاموال
والتهرب الضريبي وغيرها من التهام واوضحكم
لان التحقيق سيحدث مدى تورط الرئيس
ينضم الينا من اورلاندو توم حارب رئيس
التحالف الامريكي الشرق اوسطيله
الديمقراطيه التعقيد النصفي في الولايه
الثانيه للرئيس جوبايدنسايبدا من النقطه
الاخيره وهو موضوع التحقيقات هل ممكن ان
يذهب الجمهوريين نحو فتح تحقيقات خصوصا
بالاداء في الفتره الماضيه
والذهاب اكثر بموضوع نجله
[موسيقى]
الجمهوريين هم بانتظار همم
يتكلموا باسم همم عندهم الاكثريه
بمجلس النواب ليبدا بالتحقيقات هنالك اعدد
تحقيقات اولا مثل ما تفضلت نازل الرئيس
همم حنتر الذي عنده علاقات تجاريه مع
الصين ومع اوكرانيا وحسب المعلومات
الموجوده ضمن الجهاز الكمبيوتر الذي كان
لديه اي همم هي طلعت علاء همم يجب ان نعرف
الحقيقه ما تور الرئيس بايدن مباشره بهذا
بهذه التجاره وهل هو في تواطؤ اليوم مع
الصين ولم يحسم الموضوع بعد القمه جي 1
الذي عقدت القمه العشرين في اندونيسيا هذه
يجب ان يتحقق بها ثاني تحقيقات ستكون ضمن
السوشيال ميديا والمنصات التي تتواطئ مع
الحزب الديمقراطي همم بشكل عام
وسلسله التحقيقات هي اجهزه الامن يعني
اجهزه الامن اليوم انه بنعرف الناس القديم
الديمقراطي قام بلجنه التحقيق بالنسبه
لما حصل بالكافه البلد ولكن اليوم مالك
معلومات تقول بان اجهزه الامن كانت تواطئ
مع مجموعات عديده ويجب ان نعرف الحقيقه
الشعب الامريكي يجب ان يعرف كل هذا
الحقيقه ويجب ان تكون مكشوف اداء العام
سياسات الانفاق كتاب التش ااا يعني سلطه
الاستدعاء وضع جدول اعمال اداره اللجان
وكل هذه السلطات التي ستصبح يعني سيصبح
الجمهوريين لديهم سلطه فيها اكبر مع
السيطره على مجلس النواب هل ممكن القول
باننا ستحول الرئيس بيدن الى ما يعرف
بالليند دوت او ان السيطره على الكونجرس
تخفف من هذا الموضوع
في محوره يعني المحور التشريعي اللي هو
اللي مصلحه الحياه اليوميه للشعب الامريكي
90% على هذه المشاريع المشاريع ويستمر
بالتشريع
اما المحور الثاني وهو الميزانيه مقابل
انتاج النفط باكثريه ضمن الاراضي
الامريكيه
الحدود همم المفتوحه بين المكسيك
والولايات المتحده همم السياسه الخارجيه
هذا المحور بالذات مقابل الميزانيه التي
يطلبها الرئيس الامريكي من من الكورس
الامريكي ها هنا انا اتصور سيكون الرئيس
الامريكي بلايندر مثل ما تفضلته اما يجب
ان يتراجع عن هذه القضايا الثلاث الاساسيه
بالنسبه للشعب الامريكي ضوابط التصدير
بموضوع التكنولوجيا والتي بدائها
الديمقراطيون يعني ليس فقط الجمهوريين هل
ممكن ان تزداد اكثر خصوصا ان الجمهوريين
متشددين الى مدى ابعد بموضوع الصين وايضا
موضوع الرقابه على المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا والتي كان قد طلب بها
الجمهوريين منذ اشهر همم كيف يمكن ان يكون
المسار به الملفين
بدون شك هو كان بداوا الرئيس ترامب سابقا
وبدا يخلق نوع كان هنالك اتفاقيه توازن
تجاري ميزان تجاري بين البلدان وفرض
رسومات
وحاول ان يرفع قسم من هذه الرسومات ولكن
تصدى له المجتمع الامريكي الى حد ما ولم
يستطيع ان يرفع جميع هذه الرسومات ربما
ضمن الميزانيه الجديده الذي يجب القومي
الامريكي ان يقدمها للرئيس ربما سيكون
هنالك نوع من مشاريع جديده ضد الصين يجب
ان تكون ملتزمه فيها وبالنسبه للسين اخر
نقطه هو بيكتشف الحقيقه عن جائزه كورونا
كيف انطلقت يعني باول من طلق الكرونه
كانوا يخبرونا من همم من خارج المختبرات
وتاتنا تاكدنا بعد ذلك ان من ضمن
المختبرات من الاول هذه المختبرات نتيجه
التمويل كل اسباب التمويل يجب هذا تنكشف
الحقيقه
انا اتصور لازم يكون في هنالك محاسبه
لماذا نرسل هذه الاموال والمساعدات
العسكريه بكميات
كبيره ولماذا الرئيس بيدن لم يدعو الرئيس
بوتن ويزيلنسكي الى طاوله حوار والنقاش
وعدم استنزاف المعارك الى لاميه يعني هناك
تقارير عن بيع عدد كبير منها بالسوق
السوداء شكرا لك استاذ توم حارب رئيس
التحالف الامريكي الشرق او سطيل
الديمقراطيه
قالت وسائل الاعلام فلسطينيه قبل قليل لان
اكثر من 20 شخصا لقوا حتفهم مثلا بلا حريق
بمنزل في مخيم جباليا شمالي قطاع غزه
وتوجهت قوات كبيره من تواقم الدفاع المدني
والشرطه لتعامل مع الحريق الذي اسفر عن
وفيات واصابات ولم تتحدث اي مصادر رسميه
حتى اللحظه عن سبب اندلاع الحريق وهذه هي
الصور التي وصلتنا قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الماليه البريطاني بتاع خطه
للمواز نتضمن السيادات
في الانفاق العام لسد عجزنا في الماليه
العامه تبلغ كلفته 55 مليار جنيه استرلي
وتهدف الاجراءات الجديده الى تحقيق
الاستقرار والنمو وحمايه الخدمات العامه
وقد تضمنت رفع الضريبه الاستثنائيه على
ارباح شركات الطاقه من 25 الى 35% كما
تضمنت تمديد دعم فواتير الطاقه لمده 12
شهرا فضلا عن ضخ المليارات في التعليم
والصحه والطاقه النوويه وفي حين تلقى
الناس الخبر بحذر انتقدت المعارضه
الموازنه الجديده معتبره ان المواطنين
يدفعون ثمن فشل حكومات حزب المحافظين
قراره مؤلمه لسد عجز يقدر ب 55 مليار جنيه
في موازنهانس ربعي وزراء ماليه بريطانيا
هذا العام جمعت بين رفع الضرائب وتخفيض
الانفاق لاصلاح الماليه العامه وتخفيف
ركود طويل المحتمل واستعاده مصداقيه
بريطانيا بين المستثمرين
2028 سنزيد ضريبه ارباح الشركات الطاقه من
25 الى 35 في المئه كذلك قررنا بدا يناير
المقبل
45% على منتج الكهرباء منخفضه الكربون هذه
الاجراءات ستؤمن واربعه عشر مليار جنيه
العام المقبل
اخيرا ردخت الحكومه لرفع الضريبه على
ارباح شركات الطاقه غير المتوقعه مع
تحديدهانتلي اولويات موازنته بالاستقرار
والنمو والخدمات العامه
لكن هذه الخطه تقول المعارضه انها ستزيد
من اعداء الضرائب وسيدفع المواطنين ثمن
فشل الحكومه المحافظه حتى وان تعهدت
بحمايه الاكثر ضعفا بزياده معاشات التقاعد
في ظل ارتفاع تكلفه المعيشه
لتصحيحه اخطاء السياسه الماليه لحكومه
الجميع سيدفع المزيد من الضرائب مع خفض
الانفاق على الخدمات العامه لكن هذه
الموازنه التزمت ايضا بضخ الملياراته في
التعليم وقطاع الصحه والطاقه النوويه فكيف
يرى الناس تاثير هذه الموازنه على حياتهم
يجب ان نحضر باستقرار ولا يمكن الاستمرار
كما كنا
نعاني قبل تحسن
الوضعين في العالم الذين يعيش فيه
بعد الكشف عن الموازنه المنتظره لم تشهد
تكاليف الاقتراض الحكوميه تغيرا يذكر ما
يشير الى ان وزير الماليه نجح في طمانه
المستثمرين حتى الان ولكن كل التقارير
تشير الى ان دافع الضرائب سيشهدون اسوا
عامين مقبلين مع التوقعات بتراجع مستويات
معيشتهم باكبر نسبه على الاطلاق مصطفى
زاروه العربيه لندن
[موسيقى]
اعلنت الامم المتحده انها ستبدا في مطلع
العام القادم عمليه تفريخ النفط من
الناقله صافر الجارحه قباله السواحل
الغربيه لليمن منذ ثمان سنوات جاء ذلك على
لسان الممثل المقيم ومنسق الشؤون
الانسانيه للامم المتحده في اليمن و خلال
لقائه في مدينه عدن مع وزير النقل اليمني
اكد الممثل الاممي ان العمل الميداني
لتفريخ النفط الموجود في الناقله صافر
سيبدا في الربع الاول من عام 2023
وسيستغرق اربعه اشهر وتصل الكلفه الى اكثر
من 100 مليون دولار
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه او اطلقت كوريا
الشماليه صاروخا باليسين غير محدد وفقا ما
اعلن جيش كوريا الجنوبيه وذلك بعد تهديدها
للولايات المتحده عقب التدريبات العسكريه
التي اجرتها مع كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
[موسيقى]
سببها ذوبان الانهار الجليديه وينذر
التغير المناخي سكان الارض بكارثه وشيكا
وهي انتشار اطنان من البكتيريا الضاره وهو
معدل مقلق لكوكبنا ذوبان الانهار الجليديه
في العالم بات ظاهره تشكل خطرا محدقا على
سكان كوكب الارض والسبب ارتفاع درجات
الحراره والتي ستؤدي ايضا الى ارتفاع
مستويات سطح البحر في السنوات المقبله قال
قم باتزداد مع مرور الوقت وسيناريو ذوبان
الكليبتا واردا حيث دقه العديد من العلماء
ناقوس الخطر في هذا الخصوص ودعوا الى
التحرك بسرعه لتدارك الوضع مع تواصل ذوبان
الانهار الجلديه في اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه والتي قد تؤدي ايضا الى حدوث
انهيارات ارضيه وثلجيه وفيضانات قد تغرق
العالم الى جانب اطلاق من البكتيريا
الضاره فمن ظهور بدايه العصر الصناعي زادت
معدلات درجات الحراره حيث قدر فريق علمي
ان تواصل ذوبان ان تواصل نتوبان الانهار
الجليديه يمكن ان يؤدي الى اطلاق اكثر من
مئه الف طن من الميكروبات في البيئه على
مدار ال 80 عام القادمه وبالتالي فان
زياده تدفق الميكروبات الى الانهار
والبحيرات والمضائق والبحار سيكون له
تاثير كبير على جوده المياه النظيفه
والصحيه وصحه الانسان وفقه مراقبين في
ارتفاع درجات حراره كوكب الارض ستؤدي الى
احداث خلل كبير في النظام البيئي والقضاء
على الانهار الجليديه التي تعتبر طبعا
مخزن طبيعي للمياه المشماته
[موسيقى]
وقفي موضوع المناخ ايضا وبسبب ارتفاع
درجات الحراره ونظره المياه وزياده ملوحه
مياه الري المتوقع ان تنخفض غله المحاصيل
الغذائيه في مصر باكثر من 10% بحلول عام
2050 سنه
[موسيقى]
تخزين
التقط تلسكوب جينس وي بالفضائي صورا جديده
كشفت سحابه ضخمه من الغبار على شكل ساعه
رمليه حول نجم في طور التكوين واشارت
وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ووكاله الفضاء
الاوروبيه في بيان المشترك الى ان الضوء
المنبعث من هذا النجم يتسرب من فوق القرص
وتحته مما يتيح اضاءه الغبار المحيط وقالت
ان هذا في المرحله الاولى من تكوين النجوم
ولا يزال امامه طريق طويل قبل ان يتخلص من
السحابه الداكنه من الغبار والغاز ويصبح
نجما كاملا
ختام التاسعه مع العناوين
في ثاني قرار هذا العام الوكاله الذريه
تامر ايران بالتعاون مع تحقيقها بشان اثار
اليورانيوم وعقوبات امريكيه جديده على
طهران
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه تكشف مكونات
امريكيه ويابانيه في صناعه المسيارات
الايرانيه الى روسيا
بعباره لا خلافات سياسيه ابديه اردوغان
يجدد احتمال لقائه ببشار الاسد لكن بعد
الانتخابات التركيه
اطنان من البكتيريا الضاره التغير المناخي
ينذر سكان الارض بكارثه وشيكا سببها ذوبان
الجليد